Говорящий 1: Да,
Говорящий 1: ребят,
Говорящий 2: по стратегии партнерской сети, значит, что у нас от вчерашнего обсуждения закрепилось и что принято в целом из вчерашнего обсуждения. Закрепленная рамка – это мы один базовый продукт
Говорящий 2: запускаем изначально в партнерскую сеть.
Говорящий 2: И он является профориентацией, при этом страна, валюта, язык и состав локальной версии могут быть разными. Почему? Потому что мы на разные
Говорящий 1: рынки можем формировать. Просто мы говорим о том, что есть продукт, а дальше это уже его характеристики. Вот. И сразу же зафиксированная рамка, что один
Говорящий 2: продукт не означает одну цену во всех странах. Это мы как раз вчера тоже проговаривали про регионы, и это касается и стран тоже. Я считаю, что в одной стране мы должны единую цену ставить,
Говорящий 2: МРЦ, РРЦ, но при этом в разных регионах могут сами партнеры регулировать, мы отдаем им это на управление. В разных странах опять же та же ситуация, просто где -то в долларах, где -то
Говорящий 2: в дирхамах и так далее.
Говорящий 11: вот знаешь с товарами
Говорящий 1: есть это всякие скаю и так далее
Говорящий 14: либо
Говорящий 1: так такой же принцип цифровым товаром применим ну конечно
Говорящий 7: только бы мы перепродаем даже не только цифровые мы перепродаем еще и
Говорящий 1: разговоры конкретно с сеансом. Да, я тебе рассказывал про SPU. То есть SPU
Говорящий 2: это, например, iPhone 17. Может быть, SPU. А iPhone 17 уже может быть произведен во Вьетнаме, произведен в Китае, произведен в США. Иметь там
Говорящий 2: 256 гигабайт, 1 терабайт, иметь там, ну, в общем, Pro, Pro Max и так далее. Вот это уже
Говорящий 1: разные SPU,
Говорящий 17: которые имеют разные характеристики
Говорящий 1: связка с пою из каю смотри я не хочу сейчас уходить детали просто чтобы это как бы тоже ну такой часть исследовательскую которую я добавил чтобы ее здесь использовали ну чтобы по аналогии
Говорящий 1: было легко легко это все управлять всеми
Говорящий 9: вариациями
Говорящий 1: и ценой
Говорящий 7: и составом вот и такой еще момент то что если мы продаем
Говорящий 6: через с будем ну там через apple store или счету наш продукт должен быть не полностью цифровым
Говорящий 13: если мы хотим чтобы не весь платеж что комиссия в 30 процентов там
Говорящий 1: не снималась то есть как бы тут тоже в дальнейшем надо ну как будто гибкость она сейчас есть сейчас мы продаем чисто профориентацию один продукт
Говорящий 7: но просто учитывать саму структуру и
Говорящий 1: модель чтобы она тоже то есть партнерская система и вот контроля и учета то что вы делаете просто опережение немножко добавлю я думаю это не сильно увеличить
Говорящий 7: сложности
Говорящий 6: но вот
Говорящий 17: такое
Говорящий 7: такой момент надо учитывать тоже
Говорящий 14: то
Говорящий 7: есть мы сейчас продаем один
Говорящий 6: базовый продукт а сама методика методология партнерская позволяет подавать любые продукты то есть как это мы не тумане до
Говорящий 7: каждый эксперт может рекомендовать продукты каждого эксперта и получается на этом зарабатывать
Говорящий 21: большой и логик варень
Говорящий 7: так хорошо давайте я тогда дальше
Говорящий 6: продолжу спасибо за дополнение здесь будут
Говорящий 2: формулы формулы в принципе этом проходился по ним проверял очень интересные правильные вот Ну, они достаточно простые.
Говорящий 2: MRC
Говорящий 3: – это X, Y, X – это RRC, Z
Говорящий 2: – это сумма MainExpert за единицу. Значит, там еще появится K, а
Говорящий 17: вот партнер назначает K. K – это цена партнера.
Говорящий 17: Опять же, мы можем определить, например, для России, какие эти
Говорящий 4: величины сегодня. Я хотел бы как раз -таки, чтобы мы это зафиксировали. Вот, и, соответственно, как решение будет
Говорящий 2: пойти к
Говорящий 7: партнерам с этим всем. Так, партнер как основная роль. Опять же, вот вчера... Момент, короткий момент по поводу цены, смотри,
Говорящий 6: просто чтобы тоже, ну там не ромка, или как -то мы разобрали немножко
Говорящий 24: кейсы разных противоречий, то есть просто сценарный такой анализ, когда у тебя
Говорящий 17: есть покупатель, и вот эти все цены есть разные. И как бы партнер рекомендует
Говорящий 7: все эти цены, чтобы, ну то есть мы прошлись по чувствительности к рискам, ко всяким, в духе то, что, ну там, этично, неэтично, разные цены человек видит и так далее. Ну, это все может
Говорящий 7: быть, просто чтобы у нас была четкая здесь позиция, и она как бы была защищаемая и устойчивая долгосрочная, и все, вот такая мысль.
Говорящий 1: Давайте остановимся здесь. Хороший момент. Вчера я, как пример, большой разброс делал между МРЦ и РРЦ. Мы можем
Говорящий 33: этот коридор немного сократить.
Говорящий 2: Зачем это делается? Как раз -таки для разных регионов
Говорящий 6: цена чувствительна.
Говорящий 6: Я не думаю,
Говорящий 24: что мы сейчас должны
Говорящий 6: делать
Говорящий 24: МРЦ, РРЦ региональный, мы хотя бы для страны должны сделать, но мы можем его
Говорящий 33: сократить. Мы как раз его можем проговорить и вжать эти рамки, чтобы
Говорящий 1: базовый доход у партнера был плюс -минус одинаковый, который отличался бы на 20 -30 % между партнерами за счет
Говорящий 2: скидки, а не в два
Говорящий 1: раза, например, или в три. мы можем
Говорящий 6: и тут
Говорящий 7: важно еще все -таки гипотеза ни одного двух продуктов но это
Говорящий 1: как бы вот мысль да слуха на рыбы может быть не первичная но она позволит тогда то что в регионах будет продаваться продукт просто сам дешевого как бы состава а в крупных городах
Говорящий 7: там не знаю
Говорящий 17: какие москва питер
Говорящий 7: новосибирск такие богатые города домашекатеринбург да то есть
Говорящий 1: ну такие центры вот там может продаваться оба
Говорящий 6: продукта например ну опять же это как мысли
Говорящий 11: в
Говорящий 7: рамках одного
Говорящий 6: продукта ну
Говорящий 11: а какая проблема если бы у нас вот то что ты сейчас сказал мы делаем как ты сейчас сказал да
Говорящий 1: то есть небольшая там градация по цене и у нас один продукт который универсально
Говорящий 4: до подходит под все региону ты об этом
Говорящий 1: да вот если мы даем разницу большую давай чуть чуть
Говорящий 2: ниже как раз провисну так для наглядности вот здесь вот есть
Говорящий 3: скажи
Говорящий 32: какая
Говорящий 4: страница номер
Говорящий 32: страница 4 а
Говорящий 4: я
Говорящий 36: если что показываю демонстрации
Говорящий 3: для записи свободы
Говорящий 11: на станка да
Говорящий 7: вот это да как
Говорящий 2: раз партнер выбирает цену весь прирост сверхфиксированная зэк увеличивает его валовую дельту то есть вот как раз таки о чем я говорю что мы можем с одной стороны сильно фиксировать
Говорящий 2: разницу между y и
Говорящий 30: x чтобы здесь, например, условные 100 тысяч рублей, которые мы хотим RRC. Сумма Main Experts
Говорящий 7: может быть 50, а МРЦ может быть 80. Но тогда мы, скорее всего, условно говоря, в вакууме 10
Говорящий 2: тысяч это может быть, да там условно говоря 5 8 то есть мы защищаем доход как раз таки слабых продавцов ну
Говорящий 1: им нужно наработать этот опыт но
Говорящий 33: доход они в любом случае получают там не 5 тысяч а там 3000 условно говоря
Говорящий 3: и не
Говорящий 1: сильно
Говорящий 3: отрываем цену одну от другой я тебя услышал
Говорящий 6: я тебя услышал и понял у меня
Говорящий 11: к тебе предложение такое
Говорящий 7: методологическое то есть чтобы следующие итерации когда -то запустишь сейчас после разговора был еще раздел сценарного анализа в котором мы можем ну как бы просто синтетически
Говорящий 6: придумать ok у нас
Говорящий 7: есть такой -то
Говорящий 11: учитель
Говорящий 6: нас такая цена 10000 у нас есть такая цена там 20000 и вот эти все три цены то есть сразу же говорим то есть они вложены получаются
Говорящий 11: в этом 100000 ну и пройтись посмотреть
Говорящий 6: окей на разных регионах там
Говорящий 11: продаются какие плюсы какие
Говорящий 1: минусы то есть просто эти сценарии чтобы он несколько раз прогнал его в общей модели как бы
Говорящий 7: как будто вот ну есть эксперт у него есть они на платформу платформы есть классный продукт эксперты продают этот продукт и
Говорящий 7: тогда мы уже увидим конкретно не просто zx и y а уже сейчас можем прийти как раз той задачи который то стоит конкретные цены да а после
Говорящий 6: сценарного анализа смотри что можно сделать можно пойти как саша делает там исследовать рынок или там
Говорящий 7: вас уже какое -то исследование есть и мы видим какие есть цены ну просто сделать таблицу там по крупным региональным центром пройтись не ромка отдельно запускается исследование находит
Говорящий 7: часто занимает там не больше
Говорящий 13: думал она найдет все ключевых поставщиков похожих продуктов
Говорящий 7: и потом сделает медиану по цене среднюю цену и процентили первые пять процентов и последние 95 по цене вот и все это им я на есть и ты можешь тут
Говорящий 6: мы можем определяться то есть как бы где мы
Говорящий 11: хотим быть выше рынка по рынку и мы по стране тоже видим теперь какая -то медиана будет
Говорящий 15: ну
Говорящий 7: тогда у нас есть
Говорящий 1: позиционирование конкурентно
Говорящий 11: то есть как бы мы можем вы теперь понимаем хотя бы на примерном приближении данные по рынку понимаем что какой спред по
Говорящий 1: рынку есть даже
Говорящий 17: если допустим
Говорящий 6: не вникать глубоко в продукт потому что тут продукт тоже может меняться но в целом и теперь у нас есть коридор и мы можем конкурировать
Говорящий 11: ценой либо не конкурировать ценой о чем -то другим
Говорящий 16: да я понял тебя ты
Говорящий 17: же хочешь
Говорящий 18: чтобы партнеры зарабатывали тоже
Говорящий 17: да да да это же основная не должен они должны
Говорящий 18: конкурировать ценой
Говорящий 6: видишь то есть как бы я вот об этом думаю анализеры мы можем вообще потерять быть быть тех на которых даже не смотрят
Говорящий 21: но мы из
Говорящий 1: -за того что мы делали я вот помню опять опять же, смотри, тут вилка от двух конца, с одной стороны,
Говорящий 2: да, да, есть там бесплатные какие -то продукты по типу, вот как я скидывал, да, вот дочке прям обязательно надо было там зарегистрироваться, все, теперь профориентация есть и
Говорящий 30: государственная важная программа, все, мы теперь там будем проходить эти профориентации, я так понимаю. Есть платные всякие тоже онлайн -сервисы, я
Говорящий 6: помню, что там медиальная цена была где -то 10 -15 тысяч, Потому что были кто -то, кто -то там за тысячу, за
Говорящий 7: две тысячи делал профориентации онлайн. Были бесплатные, были те, кто там за двадцатку, за тридцатку делал. Были те, кто просто оставьте заявку.
Говорящий 6: И вот тут, ну, понятное дело, что если мы идем в
Говорящий 1: массовый сегмент, то, скорее всего, у нас будут цены медианы, близки к медианам. Но тогда будут
Говорящий 7: ли, условно говоря,
Говорящий 7: сейчас проблематику попробую выразить, будем ли
Говорящий 1: мы интересны для партнеров с той точки зрения, что они будут зарабатывать 3 -5 тысяч,
Говорящий 3: а не 30 -50 с одной продажи? ну
Говорящий 1: смотрите то есть что я слышу да и то что говоришь это на самом деле важная проблематика во первых
Говорящий 7: да во вторых здесь в любом случае опять возвращаемся к трем разным продуктом премиальный
Говорящий 6: средний дешевый ну пока пока такая классификация тогда партнеры в премиальных пожалуйста и
Говорящий 7: 50 можно зарабатывать
Говорящий 1: и больше вот то что мы с чего мы и начали помните там полмиллиона это
Говорящий 7: все эти крупные цены тогда
Говорящий 7: это вопрос решается то тот продукт в том виде в котором он сейчас он ну
Говорящий 7: наверное средний
Говорящий 7: ну его его он легко продается образно
Говорящий 17: там за 10 15 тысяч рублей легко продается то
Говорящий 6: есть
Говорящий 17: с легкостью на душе
Говорящий 6: крутить
Говорящий 7: его ну там вадим сейчас у нас просто есть более актуальна задача пристена перестраются на это докрутить хотя бы немножко но мы мы уже сделали полу версию полу обновления методологии
Говорящий 7: не полноценная на полу и она уже хорошо там прям уже классно читается уже там ну то есть исходя из того что
Говорящий 1: в тех же самых анкет ничего не меняли
Говорящий 29: уже более когда есть табельно что ли меньше
Говорящий 7: там страниц и более так профессионально вот искал термин более профессионально то есть
Говорящий 24: не какие -то там лишние фразы мы просто критически проанализировали
Говорящий 1: вадим там и не ронко просто уничтожила весь отчет как то что он вышел за рамки научности это неплохо то есть наша задача же какая чтобы у людей были гипотезы которые протестировать
Говорящий 6: чтобы они понимали а есть разные карьеры надо потестить что -то посмотреть изучить вот поэтому если на кратчайшую дистанцию в том
Говорящий 17: виде в котором есть
Говорящий 7: то ну а смотри вы же здесь что то стира мы тестируем в принципе партнерский подход и как бы в принципе чтобы сам алгоритм и сам механизм работал и партнер на премиальные протер на непремиальные
Говорящий 7: и ты вроде как универсальную схему сделал то есть может же быть такое что z y x это одна цена
Говорящий 18: вообще может быть и они тогда не зарабатывает как бы в целом
Говорящий 7: ну по сути их нет и все вот это просто мы продаем ну вот то есть как бы и по факту это вот схлапывается эти цены это наша цена сейчас а то что там небольшая дельта появляется но это
Говорящий 7: как бы как раз таки то что вот эта универсальная система нам это
Говорящий 1: позволяет а какая разница у кого -то может быть час стоит 50000 рублей например то есть сам парк сам эксперт говорит вот мой z например там 30 там я готов чтобы меня перепродавали за
Говорящий 1: 40 или там это
Говорящий 6: это получается что за цена р .с. вот давай ты мой консультант я эксперт супер английского языка
Говорящий 9: я
Говорящий 1: премиальный то есть что ты мне скажешь поставить на x
Говорящий 44: р .с.
Говорящий 7: смотри если у тебя премиальная аудитория которая тебе
Говорящий 6: платит сейчас сколько
Говорящий 1: ты за час получаешь ну
Говорящий 11: допустим мой часто 30 тысяч рублей
Говорящий 2: 30 тысяч рублей сколько ты семье в месяц этой часов продаешь
Говорящий 49: одной
Говорящий 29: семье ну два два раза
Говорящий 49: в месяц
Говорящий 1: два раза
Говорящий 33: в месяц 60 тысяч ну хорошая семья вроде бы когда значит скорее всего на x я
Говорящий 7: бы вот рекомендовал
Говорящий 24: З это вот моя цена,
Говорящий 3: то, что я хочу получить, да, получается?
Говорящий 6: З это компания получает.
Говорящий 7: Смотри,
Говорящий 6: Z это то,
Говорящий 1: сколько получит компания, а в коридоре между Y и X
Говорящий 6: может продать эксперт.
Говорящий 24: Тут смотри, получается у нас тут небольшая, надо достроить. Да, я понял.
Говорящий 3: Y минус Z или X минус Z это вот то, сколько получит эксперт.
Говорящий 24: да я тебя слышу и
Говорящий 7: я бы
Говорящий 6: тут немножко поменял чуть -чуть доработал бы как бы саму
Говорящий 7: систему партнерской еще одну итерацию сделал то есть чтобы еще бы не ровко сделала это следующий момент у нас есть платформа есть продукты
Говорящий 6: платформы есть эксперты есть продукты экспертов услуги и продукты есть
Говорящий 1: потенциальный эксперт который стал партнером и вот она вилка и тут может быть такое что как бы там же есть такая связка например если мы продаем часы эксперта на платформе просто вот
Говорящий 1: напрямую кучок пришел на платформу
Говорящий 7: за зашел видел прикольного профессора решил его купить час занятий платформа берет небольшую комиссию себе правильно но мы говорим о том, что платформа не берет наоборот комиссию. Так,
Говорящий 7: секундочку, у меня, по -моему, был расписан этот.
Говорящий 4: Вот способы заработка,
Говорящий 3: способ рекомендации услуг эксперта. Вот он.
Говорящий 4: Эксперт назначает бюджет
Говорящий 24: привлечения S от базы S.
Говорящий 3: То есть,
Говорящий 7: например, вот ты как эксперт, который 30 тысяч рублей ставишь, ты говоришь за то, что я привлеку к тебе такого клиента, ты готов со мной поделиться 10 процентов
Говорящий 18: или 20
Говорящий 7: процентов. Ты как эксперт сам назначаешь, сколько партнер получит, пригласив на твои услуги.
Говорящий 7: По рекомендательной ссылке. Да. Да, хорошо. То есть
Говорящий 23: партнером является сама платформа в этом случае?
Говорящий 8: Нет.
Говорящий 16: Нет, это отдельный человек.
Говорящий 6: Да. а
Говорящий 7: если парба
Говорящий 6: платформа привлекает то ее партнерская партнерская
Говорящий 11: да но еще есть и
Говорящий 7: партнерская которой мы здесь не учитывая я бы хотел чтобы она была ну хотя бы как бы заложено нужно может равняться нулю формуле этот
Говорящий 24: показатель должен быть то
Говорящий 1: есть ты в любой в любой платформе который ты делаешь платформа выполняет услугу и создает сделку она за это создание сделки которая схлопнулась она имеет право получить выгоду свою
Говорящий 1: каким -то процентом общей
Говорящий 18: ценности сделки это логично адекватно рационально
Говорящий 7: так ну давай вот плоды формулы рассмотрим которая здесь как раз есть
Говорящий 24: касаемо платформы, сколько она может заработать.
Говорящий 1: Вот берем 30000 те же и 10 процентов поставил эксперт, он готов отдавать. Что тогда получает,
Говорящий 6: кто сколько получает?
Говорящий 7: Мне
Говорящий 16: кажется неправильную формула, но окей.
Говорящий 7: Возможно,
Говорящий 1: возможно.
Говорящий 1: Давай попробуем докопаться
Говорящий 7: до истины.
Говорящий 7: Значит,
Говорящий 7: единица минус b так b это доля рекомендателя в этом
Говорящий 33: бюджете
Говорящий 3: бюджет привлечения с от базы с
Говорящий 7: смотри все правильно это правильно формула
Говорящий 1: это когда только есть платформа и партнер продает что -то у нее я
Говорящий 1: просто хотел расширить самую модель чтобы
Говорящий 7: была платформа и ее продукты эксперт его продукцию
Говорящий 47: и
Говорящий 7: все вот и все что я хотел просто извини она например что там 30 процентов от дохода там партнера условно говоря получает платформа да или
Говорящий 6: там ну ну примерно с моим угу кейсы ски
Говорящий 1: покидать кейсы хочешь парочку прям вот прямой
Говорящий 24: кейс просто есть платформа есть эксперт и пришел человек
Говорящий 1: трафик трафика нашего зашел и купил у эксперта или мы как -нибудь направили там создали продажу клиента с экспертом соединили все
Говорящий 24: то есть у него стоит например 3000 рублей час и мы продали за 4 или за 3 500 или за 3 300 ну то есть эти разные кейсы говорю бывало что стоит 2
Говорящий 1: 2000 вы продали за 3 500
Говорящий 14: вот
Говорящий 1: то есть это наша наценка мы как бы с наценкой продали
Говорящий 1: вот другой
Говорящий 6: вариант может быть то что у нас нету какой -то гибкой наценки и
Говорящий 24: мы просто там
Говорящий 7: берем пять процентов за транзакцию за то что
Говорящий 24: просто провели транзакцию то
Говорящий 6: что она случилась то
Говорящий 24: есть это не то что мы взяли комиссию
Говорящий 6: просто
Говорящий 25: традиционный расход который платит например
Говорящий 6: сам эксперт то есть его цена 3 500 например
Говорящий 7: указано и мы говорим что мы у тебя возьмем там не за
Говорящий 6: 350 рублей вот чтобы случилось транзакцию
Говорящий 7: там за совершение это
Говорящий 6: сделал просто фи какой -то фикс фиксированный и туда не понравилась
Говорящий 3: первая история которую ты
Говорящий 33: сказал что например эксперт
Говорящий 4: ставит свою стоимость например 3000 рублей а мы как платформа ставим на эти три тысячи рублей например 3500 я
Говорящий 7: понимаю посмотри airbnb
Говорящий 1: посмотри airbnb кейс он сейчас финальный у них кейс
Говорящий 7: у
Говорящий 1: них там тоже двухсторонняя платформа
Говорящий 24: это же разные цены и
Говорящий 1: они брали из тех из других в общем
Говорящий 6: я к чему здесь просто то что ну как бы давайте проанализируем еще мы же не
Говорящий 18: принимаешь из решения я
Говорящий 18: не помню просто там цифр но это
Говорящий 7: уход достаточно хороший кейс рациональности с кого кто что берет то есть сама платформа мы можем мы не берем например комиссии вот смотри вот он за 3500 человек нам дает
Говорящий 6: не понравился первый кейс
Говорящий 6: ну да ты говоришь не не
Говорящий 1: не мы берем с нашего конечного потребителя ну как
Говорящий 24: как в принципе в рознице тоже все и заведено то есть marketplace например он прибавляет а нет он же из этой суммы но человеку нужно самому считать,
Говорящий 6: вот человек хочет заработать, например, 10 тысяч рублей, и он понимает, что ему тогда нужно выставить
Говорящий 1: это. Здесь немножко перевернутая система, но по
Говорящий 33: сути человек
Говорящий 1: хочет заработать 10 тысяч рублей, и поэтому на платформе цена его товара 14,
Говорящий 33: потому
Говорящий 1: что 4 сверху – это комиссия платформы,
Говорящий 3: логистика, комиссии и так далее. 40%.
Говорящий 7: Но считают обычно по -другому, ты правильно
Говорящий 24: считаешь, считают неправильно считает вот так так я поставил там 60 фунтов а
Говорящий 7: комиссия 30 процентов значит я получу вот столько -то ну вроде нормально да а ну дешево да давай поднимутся
Говорящий 24: но в голове когда ты читаешь
Говорящий 14: надо
Говорящий 24: повыше сделать что если как бы вот тут играешь в обе стороны короче я тут просто саму систему и модель
Говорящий 7: смотри я бы в детали не уходил пока на этой итерации то есть кейс какой первый кейс я сказал у нас есть разные слои как раз
Говорящий 11: в этой цене так вот есть слой платформы он может быть 0 именно на оценке какой -то слой просто за транзакцию то что провели тоже
Говорящий 24: должна быть
Говорящий 1: учитываться маленькая цена то есть сама платформа за любую транзакцию собирается вы не важите порекомендовали не порекомендовали просто идет маленький фильм
Говорящий 17: линда нет согласно
Говорящий 24: до
Говорящий 6: 3 3 с половиной процента например потому что на севаринг
Говорящий 3: 07 лабора и 2 половины минимум
Говорящий 1: онлайн как там это
Говорящий 3: касса или как там что там
Говорящий 1: ну
Говорящий 17: да допустим такое и наша какая -то там 505
Говорящий 28: процента еще отчет какой -то фильм он там ты заказываешь еду 70 рублей этом заказу сама платформа берет то есть понятно что них еще есть какая -то цена цена образования не могут собирать
Говорящий 6: еще с того кто иду эту продает так вот то есть есть как бы наценка есть просто транзакционный фи есть смотри есть товар самой платформы которые могут продавать партнеры
Говорящий 7: у товара есть себестоимость это же как бы своя есть товар эксперта который может подавать платформа и могут подавать партнеры через эту платформу платформа свое все равно берет и тут
Говорящий 1: еще есть формула который ты сделал она на 90 процентов закончен там нужно добавить еще 10 процентов платформенного и все и
Говорящий 7: мы все кейсы то есть мы потом не буду возвращаться больше
Говорящий 1: к этому всякие с обхвате
Говорящий 7: просто игорь видимо исходил правильно
Говорящий 18: ну как бы я не к тому что нам нужно это брать я к
Говорящий 6: тому чтобы у нас формула была уже
Говорящий 7: готова
Говорящий 5: до зубы заложено да понятно
Говорящий 7: да цифра будет 0 например игорь если не хочет чтобы мы брали пока может быть 0
Говорящий 9: бизнес
Говорящий 7: как бы хочется чтобы если кто -то делает какое -то действие оно должно быть оплачен
Говорящий 3: да за инфраструктуру платить надо ну типа того
Говорящий 24: вот и то есть мы сейчас этот короткий комментарий можно внести сделать следующую версию
Говорящий 7: сколько заняло это сделать то что ты сейчас ну
Говорящий 24: я
Говорящий 1: вчера начал он где -то часа полтора -два я поработал и сегодня я сел где -то в 930 в 12 вот я отправил хорошо у нас тебе предложение с вадимом вадим еще этого не знает но
Говорящий 29: дай нам какой -нибудь то есть есть методология и
Говорящий 7: параллельно мы запросим допустим тебе просто на на наши этой вашей системе закинем с ним ты сейчас закинешь у себя мы закинем здесь
Говорящий 1: я наговорю как бы с водимом свой промт ты там возьмем эту транскрибацию которая вы сейчас будет и просто следующую версию сельщита улучшений учитывая вот этот добавочный контекст
Говорящий 14: и
Говорящий 18: можем потом ну
Говорящий 17: как бы еще раз созвониться можем сегодня созвониться можем какие
Говорящий 1: -то сейчас ключевые есть задачи которые надо прямо вот сейчас ответить чтобы вы могли что -то запустить потому что вилка цены она может же быть как бы позже решена или нет
Говорящий 7: но смотри там вопросы которые тоже поднимаются
Говорящий 17: сейчас что мне вылетает запустить компьютер
Говорящий 17: У меня там был список вопросов, которые… Это что? Так, это
Говорящий 3: путь клиента, путь покупателя…
Говорящий 3: А, ну в
Говорящий 1: принципе цель следующей встречи – продукты рынок,
Говорящий 6: страна валюта, состав локальной версии,
Говорящий 1: срок численный XYZ и проверяемая себестоимость. но я бы вот да я пока мы не дошли до этого лицензию может быть вообще просто так вторую идею
Говорящий 17: пока мы ну чтобы туда не распылялись может быть лицензию пока
Говорящий 24: бы не трогали
Говорящий 43: это
Говорящий 51: для кого лицей это более продажи да
Говорящий 1: это вот как предложил саша вчера историю в кейсе наших конкурентов,
Говорящий 33: где они покупают там лицензию по 6000 рублей и потом сами за
Говорящий 6: свою любую цену продают.
Говорящий 3: Да, но подписка, имеется в виду подписка,
Говорящий 17: инструмент.
Говорящий 17: Да, помню.
Говорящий 1: Да, что мне кажется
Говорящий 7: проще первых партнеров привлечь, что вот вы продаете напрямую, потому что
Говорящий 1: может быть
Говорящий 6: такая
Говорящий 7: агрессивная
Говорящий 6: обратная связь что блин чуть такое мне что что -то зарабатывать надо еще заплатить ну
Говорящий 7: вот эта история потом может работать да но как бы на начале я бы может быть смотрите
Говорящий 1: вот такая такая мысль пришла вот допустим берем всех блогеров и мы все вот сейчас представьте с блогерами говорим да допустим
Говорящий 15: привет
Говорящий 1: блогер смотри вот классный продукт вам даем его бесплатно
Говорящий 7: сделайте расскажите о нем на youtube там или в инстаграме еще где тот как
Говорящий 6: вот блин были там вопросы проблемы пыталась вот помните все это время там пытаюсь выбрать эту школу короче нашла офигенное решение реально рекомендую ребят очень классные по ссылке
Говорящий 6: проходите или к ним они и через меня вам скидку дадут вот ну там все классно и прекрасно почему
Говорящий 7: что и как вот маша вот паша вот что им хотелось а вот на самом деле что им нужно и это прям ну магия то есть я заплатила 10
Говорящий 11: тысяч там или 15000 20 тысяч сколько там вот и блин
Говорящий 1: прекрасно все сделали там за три часа я заполнил муж заполнил хотя муж с командировки был вот и сейчас сидим понимаем что будем
Говорящий 7: пересматривать планы на университет и слава богу а
Говорящий 24: то и дочь
Говорящий 17: подтверждает и такая там довольно то что я сбуду есть бутерброд их довольны такая то что да наконец -то ура я так рада вот то есть смотрите вот
Говорящий 6: есть просто кейс теперь дальше технически пошло то есть у нее есть аккаунт получается у нас системе у нее есть
Говорящий 1: ссылка реферальная она где -то там добавлено вот сразу же там есть уже у нас какая -то цена точно
Говорящий 7: и
Говорящий 1: идет скидка от нее
Говорящий 15: вот
Говорящий 1: интуитивно я вижу этот кейс вы можете свои кейсы добавлять какие хотите то есть то же самое может быть с учителем английского он пишет мариван там помните по по английскому учились
Говорящий 1: сами то есть вы
Говорящий 6: были восьмом девятом классе не знаю выбрали предмет или нет вот я у меня мои классные
Говорящий 7: партнеры друзья сделали
Говорящий 24: сервис профориентационный я там небольшую копейку с этого заработаю но как бы вам сделаю скидку реальный классный
Говорящий 1: продукт хорошее
Говорящий 7: решение вот пожалуйста если нужно там маши
Говорящий 1: то сделайте
Говорящий 7: цена приемлемая рыночная ну и в голове у
Говорящий 17: меня крутится тоже счета 20000 это где -то здесь 15
Говорящий 11: -25 15 -30 что -то вот тут где -то надо понять короче это
Говорящий 1: вопрос на рассаж к тебе и в отдельную в один в общем
Говорящий 7: к вам ребята как вам двоим и ну то есть все то есть вот смотрите большинство наших учителей часто
Говорящий 11: это тысяч пять ну там от 3 до 5 в принципе они ведут большие пакеты то есть они реально работают у них есть те кто постоянно с ними работает то есть две -три
Говорящий 7: продажи каждый из них может сделать вот просто вот там кто на профи в год давайте в год ну это моя гипотеза просто какая -то цифра анализа блогер какой -то ну если это большая аудитория
Говорящий 7: и мы можем отследить он сам доверяет то что мы все четко проверяем не не знаю сколько может тысячу продаж
Говорящий 6: делать там 10 тысяч продаж сделать вот
Говорящий 24: дай бог
Говорящий 6: но механизм
Говорящий 1: вроде похож и как бы тут надо просто
Говорящий 7: вот то что сейчас практичный как бы путь такой прагматичный вот
Говорящий 1: прямо приклад вот прямо сейчас
Говорящий 7: запустить можно и потом более такой выверенный весь
Говорящий 1: это
Говорящий 6: уже следующий этап то есть мы можем сейчас сделать
Говорящий 1: первую версию такую вот чтобы не тормозилась не тормозить весь процесс и параллельно вести еще уточнение вот этого как бы ну интернационального запуска партнерской системы
Говорящий 26: мои мысли закончились
Говорящий 7: смотри у меня примерно так и написано по поводу
Говорящий 2: инструменты учет разбора анализа 16 страница то есть как раз таки страница ссылка код с ценой к больше x
Говорящий 4: контроля акции версия условия атрибуция независимый признак ну вот инструмент
Говорящий 3: который нужно эта страница ссылка код с ценой
Говорящий 1: я читаю то что
Говорящий 7: ты здесь да у тебя написано какая -то страница у тебя на файле 16 страница вот этот момент инструменты учат посмотри чего здесь не хватает том что я говорю то что от меня чего не хватает
Говорящий 7: да то есть по сути нужно понять в кабинете у нас блогер который или партнер наш до который
Говорящий 1: хочет что -то перепродавать он в этой реферальной ссылке
Говорящий 11: сам ставить цену или он никакого влияния на цену не оказывает вот тут это гипотеза и нужно ее как бы ну просто сделать две
Говорящий 6: страницы и скинуть их
Говорящий 7: вот нашим учителям английского давай заходи что видишь он такое я вижу вот реферальная система круто окей что тут а это моя реферальная система окей супер так это мой продукт окей это
Говорящий 6: в это не мой продукт и я его продаю отлично ссылка ну то есть еще и мы проверяем как бы какое какая им версия нравится
Говорящий 24: больше какой они
Говорящий 1: хотят пользоваться
Говорящий 9: и
Говорящий 1: уже у тебя конкретные факты, что хочет партнер,
Говорящий 6: ну, как бы, можем не
Говорящий 1: проверять, вы можете это просто в голове проверить и сказать, Макс, все, точно запускаем вот такой -то сценарий.
Говорящий 7: Если не пройдет, то,
Говорящий 1: ну, как бы, какой -нибудь...
Говорящий 7: Это была цель данной
Говорящий 24: встречи, определить то, о чем ты говоришь. Вот это список того, что нам нужно для запуска. То есть это прям, ну, последняя страница, 16 -я, на ней весь список того, что нужно решить
Говорящий 24: я думаю что
Говорящий 1: на самом деле
Говорящий 55: мы
Говорящий 7: должны сами установить вот эту цену минимальную
Говорящий 55: и рекомендуемую
Говорящий 7: и в этом пороге пусть они сами уже рекомендуют непонятно делаешь итоги блогер сам поставить как
Говорящий 1: увидит по своей аудитории
Говорящий 7: правильно а может и 100000 поставить
Говорящий 14: конечно
Говорящий 7: но смотри то могут конфликты быть
Говорящий 1: именно того качества то
Говорящий 6: есть нашего обещания этой ценности которую они получат понимаешь то есть ну как бы ценность обещания и цену которую ты платишь
Говорящий 7: и тут не должно быть тоже расхождение ну давайте сейчас все подумал то есть тебе нужно вилка да это ну вот наверно 35 15 хорошо а если это премиум клиент для него не может
Говорящий 31: быть и но это премиум продукт еще
Говорящий 7: массовый
Говорящий 21: продукт
Говорящий 3: ну да если премиум продукты это дро это просто
Говорящий 4: мы можем
Говорящий 7: запустить
Говорящий 9: другими на коне
Говорящий 6: реальный смотри можем это запустить пока не премиальный потом другой запустить уже премиале даже тех же блогерам ребята короче вообще я в шоке что ребята творят буквально два месяца
Говорящий 6: назад взяла у них одну такой простой продукт дешевый
Говорящий 24: там 15 заплатили у меня же там трое детей двое детей они только что выпускает
Говорящий 1: офигенно новое обновление как будто iphone и просто про версия и тут вообще колоссально и
Говорящий 7: и и 100 и это есть и как бы зарплатная вилка и на будущее по это же тут проанализировали все короче ну я оплатила он конечно дороже стоит но блин
Говорящий 1: будущее детей дороже особенно в это непонятное время полтинник заплатила 50 тысяч вот вам со скидкой будет 40
Говорящий 6: не я заплатила 150 со скидкой
Говорящий 1: далее мир жива код
Говорящий 7: 150 нет мы мы так не пойдем бро
Говорящий 14: мы
Говорящий 24: сейчас пойдем к следующему
Говорящий 1: уровню премиальности мы просто свадим он ну блять не сможем это сделать ну это это сказочный подход ну не получается вы не сможете сделать мы не сделаем за 150 ту цену чтобы
Говорящий 24: все были довольны мы за 5070 на разделаем следующий это раз у нас будет я
Говорящий 59: не знаю
Говорящий 1: вадим ты общался
Говорящий 7: с
Говорящий 59: даниилом
Говорящий 7: по поводу его подхода чон там там нормальная база или нет
Говорящий 46: но мы вроде
Говорящий 17: что говорили но он пока еще и он
Говорящий 1: дорабатывает ну тогда смотрим но тем более давайте эти версии он от бежене нужно сразу же продавать премиальный
Говорящий 7: мы одновременно общую методику партнерки настраиваем
Говорящий 9: он
Говорящий 7: системно работала мы проверяем элементы вот там ценовая формула личный кабинет
Говорящий 1: элемент последовательность
Говорящий 7: что все цепляется но ошибки то дешевле совершать на дешевом пакете еще можно вернуть эти деньги и не будет так печально
Говорящий 29: я в общем скажу свой страх по поводу блогеров
Говорящий 6: продешевить
Говорящий 1: их
Говорящий 7: аудитории ну как
Говорящий 1: ты это поймешь что ты
Говорящий 7: продешевил очень много продаж будет ну
Говорящий 1: мы на следующего блогера
Говорящий 7: делаем другую цену
Говорящий 24: не на следующего именно у этого блогера именно вы эта аудитория
Говорящий 1: мы его закончим
Говорящий 6: он выполнит
Говорящий 1: все обязательства
Говорящий 6: все
Говорящий 1: кто купил купили это же цикл, он закроется.
Говорящий 6: Ну,
Говорящий 1: солнце зайдет.
Говорящий 9: Ну ладно, хорошо.
Говорящий 7: Пересмотрели. Не -не, нормальный вопрос. Правильно, бро, я просто тоже об этом думал уже.
Говорящий 6: Смотри, я просто аналогию в другой продукт сейчас скажу,
Говорящий 17: условно говоря, вот у меня за плечами сотни этих кладовок и, условно говоря, самое большое вот такое раздражение людей,
Говорящий 1: блин, они же стоили по 250 тысяч, как так они сейчас могут стоить 700?
Говорящий 1: Ну, типа,
Говорящий 24: я, конечно, отшучивался, мол, так тут недалеко,
Говорящий 7: всего два года назад вернитесь и купите, что вы. Ну, конечно. Нет, если посмотреть на последующие два года, то они и миллион
Говорящий 11: будут, и два будет стоить. То есть, как бы тут вопрос... Либо
Говорящий 7: подождите, я вам с удовольствием продам через два года за полтора до ну
Говорящий 1: что такое не но смотри это же другой продукт тут актив который
Говорящий 24: приносит себе доход а тут исследование которое позволяет себе предотвратить ошибки
Говорящий 14: и
Говорящий 24: как бы мы ну как бы приближаемся каждая версия у нас мы сейчас немножко ошибок только можем предотвратить ну
Говорящий 7: там раскрыть чуть -чуть понимание больше
Говорящий 1: насмотренности кстати термин саша это я у остырил
Говорящий 7: короче насмотренно сочет огонь а у вадима они помнишь самодостаточность помнишь
Говорящий 24: короче когда документ делаешь разных версий финальную
Говорящий 1: версию говорим у
Говорящий 24: сделай
Говорящий 1: чтобы этот документ был самодостаточный не было понятия что это было
Говорящий 7: предыдущей версии были вот
Говорящий 14: и
Говорящий 18: тогда он делает зависимый ну короче насчет вилки
Говорящий 9: я вам не
Говорящий 1: говорили да у меня
Говорящий 7: вышла то есть мы ошибки здесь убираем
Говорящий 1: потом следующей версии запускаем вот сейчас запускаем ну как бы ту версию которую мы протестили в чай бенске и
Говорящий 7: как бы в разных местах
Говорящий 1: мы же консультации не делаем я
Говорящий 6: консультации делают ценность добавочную консультация делает цену добавочной до 500 тысяч ну
Говорящий 17: вот
Говорящий 7: мы недавно продали 250 тысяч европейский регион ну то есть европу
Говорящий 1: но тоже через предыдущего клиента то есть кто -то другой покупал до этого а сейчас если хотим продавать через блогеров ну то есть они вот нужно должны тоже представить как это продажи
Говорящий 1: будет то есть люди которые в магазине продают в пятерочке или еще где -то в перекрестке они же там даже про полку договариваются на какой полке будет лежать как она будет лежать какая
Говорящий 1: здесь проходимость как люди это будут брать то тоже самое блогер как он будет это продавать то
Говорящий 23: есть
Говорящий 1: я вот об этом тоже думаю ну конечно мы же в принципе там два вида либо первое мы просто даем ему задачу да
Говорящий 6: и понимаем что его вводную информацию любом
Говорящий 7: случае даем и мы понимаем что он заинтересован в том чтобы были продажи более большие возобраться продукты второй вариант Мы сами пишем
Говорящий 2: шаблоны, например, тот же фрамбини, малина в шоколаде. То есть у них, это из
Говорящий 4: таких кейсов, которые на слуху последний год, у них отдел по работе с блогерами, они
Говорящий 33: сами пишут допустимые
Говорящий 24: варианты сценариев. То есть что может быть в кадре. То есть, например, что обязательно должно быть? Обязательно должен быть
Говорящий 33: продукт и обязательно его должны есть. все, все, что остальное там будет, это уже
Говорящий 33: там, креативы разные.
Говорящий 17: А
Говорящий 13: почему так? Можете
Говорящий 7: объяснить, Саш, можешь свое
Говорящий 11: мнение сказать, и ты тоже скажи, почему
Говорящий 6: именно вот они вот,
Говорящий 18: именно эти два условия как критические выбрали для такого продукта?
Говорящий 14: Парни?
Говорящий 7: А мне вопрос? Я что -то просто не очень понял вопрос. Да,
Говорящий 24: Саш.
Говорящий 4: Не, я могу объяснить, то есть,
Говорящий 3: свое мнение. Я так понял, ты Сашу хочешь послушать
Говорящий 1: я
Говорящий 29: обоих вас хотел мое мнение такое что замороженные ягоды дали что это такое
Говорящий 1: да чем на фрамбине почему именно обязательно должны кушать
Говорящий 24: не обязательно
Говорящий 7: не важно что происходит вокруг вообще там
Говорящий 1: может все
Говорящий 17: что угодно
Говорящий 24: то
Говорящий 6: что это
Говорящий 24: вызовет
Говорящий 4: доверие сам блогер
Говорящий 24: есть этот продукт
Говорящий 4: он сам является
Говорящий 6: потребителем все это
Говорящий 4: безопасно
Говорящий 7: вот то же самое то есть у нас получается человек должен на
Говорящий 17: себе этот
Говорящий 43: продукт про
Говорящий 6: пробовать и рассказать об этом или
Говорящий 6: себе на ребенке своем получается ну это один вариант либо заход просто через историю вот как я
Говорящий 29: вчерашний кейс рассказывал как тот чел блогер знакомый рекламировал того чувака он не пробовал сам продукт он вообще не в курсе что там профориентация не
Говорящий 24: профориентация но он просто через цепочку там 7 8 10 stories вот экранов просто рассказал хорошо историю
Говорящий 29: я заскринил у меня кстати сохранено это
Говорящий 6: просто разруйте
Говорящий 7: рассказал не учитывая он
Говорящий 6: использовал просто
Говорящий 11: прорекламировал да за вот
Говорящий 1: вот он просто
Говорящий 7: я не говорю вам ничего ездила ли я на нем или не ездил
Говорящий 29: да вообще
Говорящий 1: ничего вообще ничего он просто начал издалека что типа вот чел что -то вот учился там тра -та -та и вот потом создался он как -то умен заход был какой -то прикольный я уже забыл если
Говорящий 1: честно это уже давно было еще по моему в том уже году это было ну то есть но я такую углу ему люди прям этому блогеру начали писать
Говорящий 24: нифига ты заход накрутил он прям ну из лички скрины присылает типа вот это поворот типа что надевы в конце он такой типа а вот его профиль типа но есть хотите типа
Говорящий 17: подпишитесь ну
Говорящий 14: вот я вообще на обуви про волоса
Говорящий 28: звучат рабочими ну хорошо да
Говорящий 7: игорь какой еще сейчас остался у нас вопрос не закрыты давать давайте идти итеративно чтобы уже напустим ближайшее время тест запустить пилот как я говорил то есть у нас же есть учителя
Говорящий 7: вот 22 пилот два человека запусти
Говорящий 1: просто и все
Говорящий 7: давай Давай я просто проговорю, да, нет или нет, почему. Давай, давай. Продукты рынок, значит, Россия, рубли, состав
Говорящий 2: локальной версии, это вот то, что у нас сейчас есть
Говорящий 30: профориентации,
Говорящий 2: срок, ну, он автоматически это делается, численные X, Y, Z, ну вот если у тебя есть, у тебя хорошее ощущение там продукта, да, ну давай тогда. X это то, сколько наша компания может
Говорящий 30: себе заработать Давай так, начнем с Z, это максимальная цена 35, хорошо, Y это 20, это то, сколько мы даем им возможность вот этого X, это 15. То есть минимум 15 мы зарабатываем, от
Говорящий 30: 5 до 20 тысяч мы даже вот больше 50 %
Говорящий 7: можем отдавать партнеру.
Говорящий 3: Давай еще раз повторю, и ребята тоже сейчас повторите, и с чем вы согласны, с чем
Говорящий 7: нет. То есть получается, Main
Говорящий 13: Experts заберут 15 тысяч
Говорящий 7: рублей, правильно?
Говорящий 9: Да.
Говорящий 3: рекомендованная цена по продаже партнера 2035 минимальная 20 рекомендованная 35
Говорящий 1: партнер меньше 20 не дает не должен продавать
Говорящий 14: не должен
Говорящий 1: то есть по сути он может мариване позвонить сказать смотрите классного 35000 дороговато так ну давайте я узнаю может быть они мне за 25 продадут или в моменте может сказать но мне есть
Говорящий 1: скидка я могу за 25 и
Говорящий 13: 5000 он нет он тогда 10 заработает
Говорящий 32: до 10 а
Говорящий 13: если за 20 продаст
Говорящий 7: он 5 заработает ну
Говорящий 18: то есть 35 это как бы может и не приставить
Говорящий 18: да это рекомендуемая то есть там может она и выше быть
Говорящий 11: не они же я хотел ниже 30
Говорящий 40: может и ниже
Говорящий 1: до 30
Говорящий 11: 20 15 то есть 15 мы получим 5 мы ему дадим либо 5
Говорящий 1: мы ему подадим это
Говорящий 11: минимум да он получит всегда опять можно задать
Говорящий 28: либо он может ожидать
Говорящий 24: 15 либо
Говорящий 18: 20 либо пинеси
Говорящий 24: за 35 ну
Говорящий 1: тут я более интуитивно сейчас думаю то есть в целом 5000
Говорящий 3: за 15 беседы просто отправить кому -то ссылку вообще нормальная история
Говорящий 15: это
Говорящий 1: еще больше попробовать и вопрос теперь как я это делаю мне нужно теперь зайти в личный аккаунт и могу я делать 15 ссылок на себя или это всегда одна ссылка у меня
Говорящий 7: да смотри инструменты
Говорящий 24: учет разработка аналитика страница ссылка код с ценой ты можешь делать
Говорящий 1: любые коды с ценой
Говорящий 24: с любой ценой в этом диапазоне между
Говорящий 17: y и z
Говорящий 1: этот
Говорящий 28: страниц
Говорящий 17: не индексирует больше за это не сделать
Говорящий 3: можешь
Говорящий 22: рекомендованы
Говорящий 3: можно
Говорящий 17: y и выше давай так
Говорящий 6: просто там будет
Говорящий 4: просто
Говорящий 41: цена если она выше чем z это там быть просто цена
Говорящий 7: ну нам же нужно протестить чем и думаем то
Говорящий 11: то есть как бы по логике вот давайте как я буду
Говорящий 1: тестировать я учитель английского языка у меня есть фасап есть telegram вы со мной либо поговорили либо что либо у меня скинете страничку которая
Говорящий 24: объясняет именно ее прочитать вот я учитель в этом ознакомить и все я пойму профориентация
Говорящий 1: вот ее методика все
Говорящий 7: и теперь я должен стать партнером я стал
Говорящий 1: партнером чем не нужно вам дать и пани п
Говорящий 7: что там должно быть
Говорящий 17: Смотри, это вопрос
Говорящий 1: условия и
Говорящий 41: выплаты платежи и правовая проверка. Налоги и документы по выбранной стране. То
Говорящий 38: есть, соответственно, у нас есть ИП Александр Бондаренко, на который уходят
Говорящий 24: оплаты.
Говорящий 24: применимость применяется у нас сроки расчетов я
Говорящий 17: считаю что у нас
Говорящий 24: какой там 14
Говорящий 17: дней до на возврат
Говорящий 7: закон
Говорящий 14: мы
Говорящий 24: можем через 14 дней
Говорящий 1: делать выплату
Говорящий 24: по поводу эквайринг
Говорящий 1: и валютные расходы естественно несет компания, поэтому мы говорим про 15 тысяч
Говорящий 14: минимум,
Говорящий 1: потому что налоги скорее всего берем
Говорящий 33: тоже мы на себя.
Говорящий 7: Но так как мы не являемся, как
Говорящий 18: это называется, валютным агентом, забыл как это называется, мы можем, например,
Говорящий 6: человек продал за 30, мы ему можем 15 тысяч перевести и это его задача
Говорящий 1: заплатить
Говорящий 7: ндфл
Говорящий 1: 13
Говорящий 7: процентов
Говорящий 1: то есть он у нас подписал оферту
Говорящий 7: агентского договора галочкой
Говорящий 1: и дальше а в ней прописано что мы за него не платим то
Говорящий 43: есть мы не являемся его там как это
Говорящий 7: проверить просто проверить начали лишь к проверьте потом можно юриста проверить то есть как бы я не против
Говорящий 6: я мне кажется звучит логично все просто чтобы это на бумаге у нас была проверка следующей версии когда ты сделаешь чтобы это тоже учитывалось у нас есть ну даже вот родион
Говорящий 17: общались он уже давно
Говорящий 6: ждет он готов у
Говорящий 11: них там есть инстаграм и они там все сделали
Говорящий 17: тесты
Говорящий 11: то есть в
Говорящий 17: принципе как бы у них уже если понимание
Говорящий 7: не сами прошли она может это выложить везде и как бы посмотреть как среагирует аудитория все можно переговорить вот так же взять у него все данные там у
Говорящий 6: них есть все есть вот и проверить просто вот как будто бы она там блогер сказать что должно быть можем отправить и там видео записать приедет кто -то запишется видео
Говорящий 11: выложит она может на телефон это сделать как бы вот
Говорящий 7: эти все вот этапы то
Говорящий 11: есть это виз взаимодействие ну тут уже получается
Говорящий 1: как блогер вот
Говорящий 4: смотри вот здесь есть продажа и бренд основатель плюс маркетинг вот продажа и бренд
Говорящий 55: Кто продает? Продает, например, партнер, принимает оплату, компания Main
Говорящий 7: Experts, ИП Александра Бондаренко, отвечает семье, там автоматически платформа отвечает семье. То есть
Говорящий 24: дальше вся коммуникация идет платформы, степень публичного
Говорящий 7: упоминания Main Experts. тут, как по мне,
Говорящий 7: отдаем на пожелания партнера. То есть
Говорящий 1: он может говорить название компании, может не говорить, просто говорить, там классные ребята. Вот как я Таня, там классные ребята, я ей вообще, ну то есть ей
Говорящий 7: все равно было, как эти ребята называются. То есть ей главное, чтобы порекомендовали классный продукт.
Говорящий 7: Границы личного предложения. Здесь я
Говорящий 33: считаю, что на усмотрение
Говорящий 18: партнера. то есть он может рекомендовать как угодно в любой форме не порочащий
Говорящий 3: честь и достоинство компании мне
Говорящий 18: очень понравилось знаете ли вы какой -то способ заработать
Говорящий 7: в интернете но не крипто
Говорящий 32: да я
Говорящий 7: просто отвечаю я комментирую все
Говорящий 18: да
Говорящий 3: да еще авиасейл конечно и сам мемщики крутые
Говорящий 46: вопросами ребят есть
Говорящий 4: позволите смотрите если
Говорящий 30: компания main experts сама продает продукт сама вот на профориентация
Говорящий 4: какой какая цена установлена на подходу
Говорящий 6: никакой ребят
Говорящий 11: ответ по ходу что этот
Говорящий 7: продукт который мы так продаем у нас не будет системе
Говорящий 22: а мне кажется 35 или
Говорящий 1: типа сами думать а они могут не подешевле чем мы даже продать ну и слава богу
Говорящий 6: да да да мы
Говорящий 7: можем выше р р р ц поставить 50000 мы можем поставить
Говорящий 18: хватит говорить это может давайте сейчас то что
Говорящий 6: 50 тысяч, мне кажется, нам надо поставить 50 тысяч,
Говорящий 33: а партнеры сами будут уже…
Говорящий 1: У них же даже на лендинге сразу будет 50 зачеркнуто, 35 или 20, ну то есть уже будет зачеркнутая
Говорящий 7: цена. Плюс, плюс, плюс.
Говорящий 1: Да,
Говорящий 7: если они будут выставлять цену выше, чем 50, то
Говорящий 46: этой зачеркнутой цены не будет, там просто будет вот
Говорящий 25: такая -то цена.
Говорящий 3: Ну то есть, а как они продают выше, если человек зайдет и увидит у нас на платформе
Говорящий 4: 50?
Говорящий 9: А как он зайдет
Говорящий 7: и увидит?
Говорящий 24: Так, подожди, в чем вопрос? Ну, увидит он выше 50, и что? Не понял.
Говорящий 25: Ну, другой
Говорящий 24: продукт может?
Говорящий 33: Нет. Ну, тот же даже, ну, зайдет, увидит дороже. У партнера дешевле. В общем, вопрос
Говорящий 29: не понял. Не -не -не, если у партнера дороже, если партнер продаст дороже.
Говорящий 7: Нет, есть сценарий, Саша, когда партнер, например, ставит 70, а у нас на сайте 50.
Говорящий 6: Я считаю, что нужно этим пренебречь.
Говорящий 1: Потому что, опять же, вот есть кейс,
Говорящий 24: который уже продают, у них 6 тысяч себестоимость. То есть за 6 тысяч может пройти человек. Я вижу, что люди на своем канале продают за 50. За 50 и за 80. И как бы никто не парится этим
Говорящий 24: вопросом. Я предлагаю тоже сейчас
Говорящий 6: этим вопросом не париться.
Говорящий 24: Я единственное бы пометку
Говорящий 7: поставил, юридически разобрать
Говорящий 1: этот
Говорящий 7: кейс. И все.
Говорящий 47: в
Говорящий 7: целом согласен потому что ну крайний случай чем мы не делаем продукта с нашей платформы только партнерские продажи идет правильно можем же так можем потом
Говорящий 7: можем сделать
Говорящий 13: как ты сказал там 35 они там могут ниже делать
Говорящий 1: продавать можем отлично
Говорящий 17: звучит логично на
Говорящий 1: сайт зашел 50 а как
Говорящий 17: это дать через себя ну мы просто с ними этот ну как я
Говорящий 16: партнер платформы
Говорящий 4: я платлю партнер платформы мне там они со студентами помогают там еще что -то или там да я у них
Говорящий 7: провожу уроки
Говорящий 1: то есть я
Говорящий 18: являюсь частью экосистемы поэтому через меня можно дешевле
Говорящий 29: супер слушай почему то
Говорящий 7: 70 то я у них вижу
Говорящий 29: 50 ну
Говорящий 7: может они обновили довольцы на скипка какая -то когда
Говорящий 55: мы
Говорящий 24: и вижу
Говорящий 6: но возможно
Говорящий 1: это не не тот пакет потому что я тебе же еще буду услуги оказывать
Говорящий 6: ничего не мешает тоже от себя давать какую -то дуб консультацию вот ну да
Говорящий 1: там же просто техническое исполнение как бы тут тебе же консультация важно вот и со мной бушку
Говорящий 1: кстати ребят на ведь какая прикольная тема вот
Говорящий 7: эксперт начинает продавать за 20 мы ему знаете что я думаю сделать нам нужен верх поставить
Говорящий 25: нужно поставить цену выше которой нельзя
Говорящий 6: вадим об этом думает я обязательно прям что я вижу причем
Говорящий 18: я ем хот -дог где пришел inside это не просто
Говорящий 14: почему
Говорящий 24: зачем нужна верхняя планка ну просто так давай до конца добью мысль смотрите можно прикольно сделать то есть у
Говорящий 1: нас есть полностью план обучения по нашей профориентации ты проходишь этот план и получаешь на сертификат
Говорящий 18: ну там как тестирование так далее сертификат получил
Говорящий 7: теперь ты можешь делать консультации все
Говорящий 7: теперь ты можешь продавать этот продукт ну максимальная цена плюс консультация
Говорящий 1: это первый момент как раз то что ты сейчас сказал ты же не просто покупаешь продукты же еще со мной больше это все общаться
Говорящий 7: вот
Говорящий 11: тогда он он имеет право это делать второй момент ну цена и ценность то есть может
Говорящий 13: быть такое что бля я не знаю 670 это
Говорящий 1: конечно пиздец разница ну бывает и выше разница согласен
Говорящий 3: просто негатив он будет копиться блогеру пофиг то нам не пофиг вот речь
Говорящий 29: да не будет он копиться вот мое мнение они вообще вот знать не знают они
Говорящий 24: увидели этого блогера
Говорящий 29: ну пошли но заказали
Говорящий 24: у него на купили
Говорящий 29: умели вообще до
Говорящий 7: лампочки миллион поставил давай вот сценарий миллион рублей
Говорящий 11: и и расколся покупатель хренины новое мы
Говорящий 1: получили с этого 20000 30 20 он получил 980 тысяч и
Говорящий 22: и п на и п к
Говорящий 3: мы еще на вага заплатили
Говорящий 38: 60
Говорящий 3: тысяч
Говорящий 18: миллиона мы заплатить
Говорящий 5: но здесь еще тут еще вот вопрос
Говорящий 1: если мы платим то это не очень удобно если он принял на себя этот миллион рублей нам заплатил вот эти минималку 15 это еще проще ну
Говорящий 7: то есть тут тогда уж лучше вот такой
Говорящий 6: вариант что он на себя пусть принимает
Говорящий 29: не все согласятся и не все тебе переведут обратно
Говорящий 24: нет смотрите
Говорящий 1: в смысле не все не переведут если он не переводит то и уж пакет не активируется клиент платит ему он говорит вот переводи мне там на тиньков
Говорящий 24: на т -банк до 20000 например чтобы ему открыть для этого пользователя, ему нужно сперва заплатить нам, а потом уже скинуть ссылку
Говорящий 17: этому клиенту на прохождение.
Говорящий 24: Ребят, а почему трехглавый дракон — это отрицательный персонаж?
Говорящий 14: В смысле?
Говорящий 7: Ну, в сказках. Почему он является того, кого пытаются убить? Так он же
Говорящий 18: съедал все время, деревню съел, еще кого -то там съел.
Говорящий 7: Ну, тут он, конечно, да, ошибся, я согласен.
Говорящий 17: Но в целом, что я заметил,
Говорящий 1: то что у
Говорящий 11: нас сейчас четыре
Говорящий 1: головы это пипец как круто то есть по сути что ты говоришь саш то что он партнер оплачивается своей карты как спонсор клиента
Говорящий 9: да и
Говорящий 7: потом скидывает ссылку уже на прохождение просто тут то он кидает ссылку на страницу
Говорящий 11: и там оплата идет как будто клиент заходит ты говоришь немножко другой workflow
Говорящий 15: продажи
Говорящий 6: который
Говорящий 14: имеет место быть
Говорящий 1: ими
Говорящий 6: а это быть но в этом подход
Говорящий 1: котором твоем там максимальной цены может не быть соглашусь который
Говорящий 7: мы
Говорящий 1: сейчас прорабатываем там должна
Говорящий 7: согласен с тобой точно точно согласен
Говорящий 29: уставлям принять на это даст согласен за согласен продуктивно
Говорящий 11: что вам скажу мне нравится я уже спокоен
Говорящий 6: высоков всего тут открыли блин реально рабочая схема
Говорящий 47: еще
Говорящий 6: у меня второй
Говорящий 4: вопрос был по поводу первое если сам продает компания сама вроде ответили данном возможно либо так либо так либо вообще не продает ли продает допустим по рэйр цепочку а второй вопрос
Говорящий 4: не был такой по поводу учителей вот смотрите учителя которые
Говорящий 30: например преподают на тетр фуля они ставят свою цену какую они хотят учили
Говорящий 36: стоит там 30
Говорящий 4: фунтов
Говорящий 36: например платформа
Говорящий 23: ставит сама рассчитывает
Говорящий 36: ну по своим критериям цену по своей
Говорящий 6: методике и ставит цену на него там 55 фунтов
Говорящий 17: и
Говорящий 7: их это не устраивало потому что он говорит что за 55
Говорящий 1: я уже получаюсь там совсем как бы ну да достаточно дорогим меня мало берут
Говорящий 1: вот хрен получает 30
Говорящий 38: и то есть как бы вот этот момент такой то что мне это не нравится это был такой негатив вот соответственно
Говорящий 6: когда мы говорили по поводу краски наценок и
Говорящий 30: нацелок мы говорим смотри ты приходишь ставишь говоришь на цену ты ее и получаешь все ее и клиент платит и платишь а мы монетизируемся по -другому ну допустим здесь может быть какая
Говорящий 30: -то либо комиссия
Говорящий 36: небольшая либо какая -то другая монетизация виде подпискам и так далее вот если же мы продаем урок этот сервис партнеров то он получается
Говорящий 4: сразу ну
Говорящий 4: то есть как как это работает где его цена которую он получит учитывая то что он как учитель хочет больше зарабатывать может хочет больше зарабатывать он не хочет
Говорящий 7: удовольствоваться минимальной ценой которая вот ему платить и все то есть ну вот не знаю я здесь пока не очень вижу
Говорящий 36: как как должно быть
Говорящий 1: правильно может быть но смотри ты про портфа или ты про другой продукт говоришь нет
Говорящий 38: нет я про
Говорящий 7: час
Говорящий 38: занятий учителя которому
Говорящий 4: привлекли умерть
Говорящий 7: умерть и предложения чтобы ты тоже подготовил короткий такой с лишкой ответ как раз такой вопрос ты задай этот вопрос подготовь ответ ну что очень важный здесь но немножко другого продукта
Говорящий 7: касается и
Говорящий 17: мы как раз к следующей версии когда придем ну ты нам это дашь все и
Говорящий 7: лишь
Говорящий 17: просто давайте попробовали
Говорящий 18: бы вопросы которые у
Говорящий 17: нас будет который будет стоять да
Говорящий 6: и саш вот
Говорящий 1: ты говоришь про эту верну любой вверх
Говорящий 6: ты можешь
Говорящий 1: все как бы отдельно звучит давайте сейчас пока без нее вот хотя бы на первой итерации что мы
Говорящий 7: могу
Говорящий 6: могу конечно
Говорящий 22: ну давайте давайте без нее
Говорящий 7: то есть мне
Говорящий 18: нравится идея чтобы другие другие зарабатывать а хоть он зарабатывать и
Говорящий 7: реального кофе давайте зарабатывать довольны быть еще рекомендовать
Говорящий 1: но какая у нас сейчас задача мы хотим протестить
Говорящий 7: что сама система работает что все ватам ссылочки работать что кабинет работает партнера ну то что там запустил первый запуск запустить 12 через
Говорящий 1: партнера тоже все ссылки работают там два тричок купила платежи все прошли они все сделали им отчеты отправились, нагрузка нормальная, ничего не упало, прошли 14 дней или сколько -то
Говорящий 1: дней, мы сделали выплаты.
Говорящий 1: Вот я бы вот это все, чтобы
Говорящий 7: пилотное было прям отработано. И
Говорящий 6: потом уже добавим усложнение, которое ты говоришь, Саш, и
Говорящий 15: потом
Говорящий 1: на другой продукт
Говорящий 6: перейдем, как ты
Говорящий 1: говоришь, Вадим. И то, что я там искаю, все остальное начало с самого начала, это тоже можно потом перенести.
Говорящий 6: Хорошо. Хорошо. Смотрите, вот эти два флоу они
Говорящий 17: расписаны в
Говорящий 6: картах процессов вот тот когда деньги принимает партнер он на
Говорящий 17: странице 11 когда
Говорящий 6: принимает по рекомендации клиент приходит сразу принимает main
Говорящий 4: experts он на странице 10 то есть эти два флоу они в принципе расписаны то есть что выполняет партнер на каком этапе что получает семья при этом и
Говорящий 3: какая ответственность в main expense когда у партнера покупает
Говорящий 6: там деньги да там как идут и условия
Говорящий 7: выполняется как когда к нам приходят вот
Говорящий 6: смотрите все круто это я вижу ее
Говорящий 24: перед глазами тут один момент только я бы еще сделал один уровень детализации то
Говорящий 17: есть
Говорящий 7: еще делается одна карта слоем ниже по иерархии
Говорящий 11: то есть больше деталей больше точности больше стрелок если вложенность вот в каждом виде запрос что это
Говорящий 1: значит там это это это то есть разбить еще тогда
Говорящий 7: мы можем увидеть
Говорящий 1: потенциальные риски ошибки и еще
Говорящий 17: что то просто это да ну как бы это верхнеуровневая карта то
Говорящий 7: будет низ ниже
Говорящий 17: нижний уровень
Говорящий 7: тогда мы можем
Говорящий 17: вот этот нюанс учесть потому что сейчас этот нюанс как бы тут не то
Говорящий 7: есть видит запрос передает ссылку
Говорящий 1: покупают рекомендации и
Говорящий 1: технически тоже хочется как то чтобы надо будет потом через
Говорящий 7: ребят пропустить но вот не знаю я помню был этот dropbox вроде бы dropbox или как он там
Говорящий 3: был такой сервис может
Говорящий 3: существует да
Говорящий 1: и я помню их они рекомендовали тебе давали эти гигабайты
Говорящий 7: за рекомендацию вот и там прям все ну ты реально хочет бесплатно год у тебя что были эти
Говорящий 23: там ссылки кидаешь просто всем подряд
Говорящий 7: или сараешь
Говорящий 6: себе
Говорящий 7: дополнительные аккаунты на другие и мэйлы
Говорящий 6: ну или такое делаешь
Говорящий 1: еще что -то ну любом случае как бы это понятно что
Говорящий 6: систему можно играть с ней но они все равно хорошо выросли то есть у них была вирусности
Говорящий 7: люди оставались потом и платили продолжали платить и те платежи которые у них были они покрывали их себестоимость развития
Говорящий 1: команду всех всех содержали на три есть успех коммерческий успех то есть сейчас задача в принципе такая стоит чтобы все что на и п будет приходить она покрывала все российские расходы
Говорящий 1: наш
Говорящий 18: смотрите
Говорящий 1: время на партнерку будет тратиться то есть ты будешь каждым партнером разговаривать или нет сейчас пилотно да можно с каждым потом наверное думаю надо как -то пробовать уже не с каждым
Говорящий 1: что
Говорящий 18: еще какие еще мысли ну выплаты чтобы до автоматически были как
Говорящий 7: мы сейчас поймем
Говорящий 18: удобно лёг
Говорящий 7: как
Говорящий 11: вот мы поймем что все ок да говорит ты правильно еще говорили я хочу сказать что для
Говорящий 1: партнера ты заходишь выбираешь продукт и
Говорящий 4: у тебя удобно в вилку минимальные максимальной цены и и может им по звукам крутить там туда
Говорящий 3: -сюда например хорошо
Говорящий 7: вопрос вопрос аж тебе тоже игорь тоже смотрите я блогер я все покрутил сделал цены 35 такое все так выходные сейчас там я не знаю день учителя все закидываем так ребята день учителя
Говорящий 7: короче всем учителям всем там
Говорящий 11: вот по профориентация всем родителям все круто делайте покупайте
Говорящий 1: по ссылке переходите скидка будет вам
Говорящий 9: вот
Говорящий 1: через какое -то время он ставит еще одну ссылку делать но уже другую цену а это все еще активно
Говорящий 24: нормально
Говорящий 14: нормально вообще
Говорящий 6: это история
Говорящий 2: она постоянная я поэтому говорю что бывает какая -то часть просит либо возврат либо компенсацию какую
Говорящий 24: -то но это чем закрывается что на тот момент бы была такая вам были вам даны такие условия сейчас условия другие если там возможны условия окей вы можете получить
Говорящий 7: возврат денег пойти там купить но мы естественно партнеру говорим и братан у тебя тут как бы не бьется ты уж либо на брата
Говорящий 6: не сиди на двух стульях
Говорящий 9: да да
Говорящий 11: вроде нормально не знаю на первом приближении
Говорящий 7: я пока конкретику начинаю видеть уже
Говорящий 7: какие дальнейшие
Говорящий 1: действия какие дальнейшие шаги самые важные критичные саш как ты видишь и
Говорящий 18: игорь как ты видишь
Говорящий 18: но на ближай я партнер не особо
Говорящий 6: много мыслей одну
Говорящий 18: мысль скажи самую
Говорящий 7: критическую важную надо
Говорящий 6: опылять
Говорящий 7: надо опылять нужно как можно больше
Говорящий 1: с большими количеством
Говорящий 7: людей соприкоснуться
Говорящий 1: и предложить
Говорящий 17: ну если брать вот
Говорящий 7: ближайшие пять дней сколько людей ты думаешь будет нормально ну
Говорящий 7: чтобы так вот лично
Говорящий 11: персонализировано ну вот минимум 10 вот прям лично персонализировано так про какие -то ссылки в чат и и там про что
Говорящий 7: -то еще там я молчу там невозможно
Говорящий 17: 10
Говорящий 23: партнеров на этой неделе проверить протестить
Говорящий 6: надо ну
Говорящий 6: хоть хотя бы соприкоснуться
Говорящий 1: и как -то вот не просто типа вкинул он прочитал и ничего ничего не ответил а имеется ввиду вот по
Говорящий 17: взаимодействовать то есть как такое
Говорящий 6: предложение игорь
Говорящий 1: сделаешь потому что в google доксу себя просто нам ссылку кинь типа excel там имя фамилия данные и так далее я тебе дам свои какие -то контакты кто может быть партнеры там 23 вадим
Говорящий 1: посмотри может кто -то в грузии
Говорящий 6: там есть учителей кого -то просто потестить
Говорящий 5: вот
Говорящий 6: что
Говорящий 7: еще саш ну тебе такой же вопрос может кто -то есть потенциально там подруга бы мамы брата жениха которая преподает французский
Говорящий 7: язык и новолетов
Говорящий 18: у меня помладший контингент у меня пока до 10 лет что нити ну
Говорящий 7: ну хорошо тогда можно по -другому сделать у нас есть таблица вот в профи там психологи
Говорящий 6: игорь с ними тоже поаккуратнее потому что они психологи ну то есть тут как бы все может быть от них не знаю что ожидать вот можно найти учителей как бы таких у меня есть учителя которые
Говорящий 24: активно учителя но они
Говорящий 7: не блогеры то есть тут как бы мира две категории да есть надо протестить которые типа блогеры небольшой базы подписчиков может быть они могут
Говорящий 18: быть узконаправленные предприниматели правильно ведь
Говорящий 14: надо почему нет
Говорящий 1: ведь 100 просто дети под дети и подростки у всех есть то есть получается 2 2 или 3 когорты то есть чисто блогеры такие медийные чуваки которые там все рассказывают есть какие -то предприниматели
Говорящий 1: которые о своем продукте
Говорящий 7: рассказывают или там выкладывают красивые картинки там не знаю
Говорящий 6: путешественник там отели продает отели выкладывают там еду еду
Говорящий 7: готовить там вот и учителя
Говорящий 24: есть правильно
Говорящий 7: у
Говорящий 1: меня есть такой
Говорящий 7: ученик который идет свой по биологии
Говорящий 1: прикольным ему там не знаю сколько нас на 1500 заработал со все время вот ну денис есть
Говорящий 24: тоже игре все это тебе говорю еще ну то есть все для тебя сейчас
Говорящий 7: и выбирать что нужно как нужно мы тебя поддерживаем скажи только что надо от нас еще
Говорящий 1: слушай но я перед тем как звонить до базу это важно собрать
Говорящий 24: я перед тем как звонить контактировать с людьми все -таки хотел бы но иметь какие -то материалы которые им скинуть вот встреча прошла не такие
Говорящий 6: но окей скиньте ссылку да вот так а может чтобы
Говорящий 7: сразу уже с ними и запартнерится
Говорящий 18: то есть и материалы и чтобы технически все
Говорящий 24: работало да да да да ну то есть хотя бы mvp было технически что мы завели вот статус партнера может
Говорящий 4: быть даже пока что без
Говорящий 4: экзаменации без выдачи сертификатом и потом да да конечно
Говорящий 5: конечно то
Говорящий 1: есть было у них был вот этот инструмент формирования их быстрой ссылки
Говорящий 2: как вот я саша
Говорящий 1: написал сашскими
Говорящий 2: land он мне коп скинул все я отправил там оплатили да то есть вот чтобы потенциального партнера было максимально был максимально легкий flow и достаточность инструментов для отправки
Говорящий 4: материалов тогда тебе
Говорящий 6: обратный вопрос тебе обратный вопрос можешь пожалуйста
Говорящий 17: сделать flow вот там ты уже сделал теперь конкретный flow и списком прям сколько
Говорящий 7: тебе нужно материалов и каких какое какие цели для чего они нужны что они должны быть не готова
Говорящий 14: и
Говорящий 7: как бы
Говорящий 6: как раз таки и они будут с путя
Говорящий 24: сочетаться ставим flow на этом флоу какой -то материал на этом такое то может на этом все три или там все пять и вот у тебя достаточно flow достаточно детализированный и материалы подготовим
Говорящий 24: себе
Говорящий 1: потом мы это отдаем все программистам они быстро делают и у
Говорящий 1: них же тоже не ронг они тоже там вайб кодят им тоже нужна спецификация спецификации готовишь
Говорящий 1: вот
Говорящий 3: это спецификация то что ты сейчас сделал
Говорящий 17: сейчас секунду у меня вроде было это либо либо сейчас
Говорящий 3: секундочку я к точке предложения
Говорящий 17: вот смотрите инструменты цены
Говорящий 24: и страны вот мне это было странице 1 продуктовая основа локальное предложение надежная фиксация каждой продажи вот компонент
Говорящий 2: личная страница ссылка показывает конкретные продукты цену поддерживает к там в общем код определяет предложение для автора рекомендации ну в общем проверка мрц понятно фиксация заказа
Говорящий 2: сохраняет все это и возможность возврата отмены если
Говорящий 3: она наступает
Говорящий 3: ну как это
Говорящий 6: вроде не все это flow да здесь больше функция как бы
Говорящий 29: но это то что да должно быть у парни на самом ну да элемент
Говорящий 46: карточка
Говорящий 3: партнера паспорт партнера там
Говорящий 18: у
Говорящий 7: меня есть путь партнера
Говорящий 2: опять же но так первая итерация хотя бы это хорошо куда ему идти
Говорящий 30: разобран и
Говорящий 4: попал есть тоже начиная к ростике на 9 странице подключения партнера то есть как его этап
Говорящий 17: знакомства этап модели условий
Говорящий 1: принимает условия и готовность создает все свои материалы для того чтобы отправлять ссылку то есть первое приближение уже тоже есть в этом файле
Говорящий 7: это прекрасно было я прям более чем уверен что ты все круто сделал я вижу то что у тебя уже хорошо я просто к чему сделать уже вторую терацию которая
Говорящий 6: будет потом посмотреть еще еще нужно да то есть потому что здесь получается
Говорящий 17: три стороны то есть мы партнеры
Говорящий 1: клиентup платформа платию
Говорящий 13: партнеры есть и клиент клиенту что -то нужно будет от партнера партнеры что -то нужно будет от нас
Говорящий 1: партнера должна
Говорящий 7: быть вся инфраструктура которым будет пользоваться и которым он может передать клиенту у партнера должно быть понимание тоже процессов и
Говорящий 6: карта его процесса
Говорящий 1: и он тоже
Говорящий 6: наглядно все это видит
Говорящий 24: для себя я партнер продаю и по цене он тоже наглядно видит смотрите вот пример вы продали этот пакет по такой -то цене заработали 5000 то есть такая презентация своему
Говорящий 11: объясняет
Говорящий 27: вот
Говорящий 11: и потом может быть страничка примеров как можно это все сделать если вы там через чат там потому
Говорящий 6: что и рок все это может
Говорящий 1: нарисовать конкретный кейс там вы общаетесь с родителем ребенка вот вы там через блок вы там в инстаграме или еще где -то вы там на ютюбе запишите расскажите вот это просто как пример
Говорящий 1: примера кейсов все
Говорящий 7: смотрит у него фантазия узкая мы ее расширили
Говорящий 6: у него страхи
Говорящий 7: мы их убрали
Говорящий 6: у него непонимание как дальше действовать мы ему показали как
Говорящий 7: теперь он вероятно что он ошибется низкая вероятность то что конверсия случится высокая
Говорящий 9: ну
Говорящий 7: в общем да это первое приближение большинство этих вопросов которые ты задаешь здесь уже они
Говорящий 1: отвечены
Говорящий 7: и и по флоу и повод смотри партнер
Говорящий 6: семья а сейчас секунду от валька ничего пусть даже отключено
Говорящий 17: будет я бы запомнил в голове держу картинку у меня есть ну
Говорящий 1: ребята можешь включить и конечно оплата здесь я все вижу да вот это брат вы если идти все есть
Говорящий 40: да то есть в
Говорящий 7: воздухе возврата
Говорящий 22: здесь вроде нет
Говорящий 7: возврат есть сейчас я покажу где он это по flow непосредственно
Говорящий 1: путь партнера его заработка
Говорящий 1: я где -то это делал а это вот инструмент это в
Говорящий 24: самом инструменте внутри
Говорящий 7: есть функция возврата либо отмена
Говорящий 6: точно ну супер
Говорящий 7: ну там надо
Говорящий 6: ее просто распространить
Говорящий 7: час сквозное чтобы она в процессе попала
Говорящий 24: и
Говорящий 7: например вот здесь когда клиент
Говорящий 24: приходит по рекомендации вот сюда тоже можно
Говорящий 18: ну да просто если возвраты будут ручными и мы их не обсудим то как бы мы потом просто
Говорящий 7: здесь вот он как бы можно сказать что
Говорящий 24: завершает
Говорящий 7: расчет учитывает
Говорящий 24: корректировки выплачивает
Говорящий 7: а вот
Говорящий 24: здесь возврат и есть то есть но как бы это один из сценариев период выплат
Говорящий 1: и
Говорящий 6: я думаю нам нужно будет показать
Говорящий 7: какие -то успешные кейсы еще то что вот ну там такой
Говорящий 6: -то учитель в таком -то городе
Говорящий 7: помогает родителям получает
Говорящий 1: дополнительно получила от нас дополнительно в этом месяце там 30 тысяч
Говорящий 7: рублей
Говорящий 14: лигала
Говорящий 7: чтобы тут не было никакого наеба
Говорящий 6: вот смотри даже есть экономика и панель результата показываем
Говорящий 33: выгоду партнера умный расчет период
Говорящий 33: положены средняя цена и дельта результат
Говорящий 6: после расходов расчеты с платформой лицензию 14 знаешь
Говорящий 1: комментарии почти 14 странице ну именно потом когда документам которые мы применяем
Говорящий 7: уже прикладные такие то все эти формулы нужно ну во -первых понятно ну то есть менее абстрактных примерами описать чтобы понимание партнера было прям ну как трехлетний ребенок, ему
Говорящий 7: все понятно.
Говорящий 6: Слэш как он, dash ten level или как он
Говорящий 29: там в этом,
Говорящий 1: в чат GPT.
Говорящий 7: И он пишет
Говорящий 1: понятным текстом для
Говорящий 3: ребенка 10 лет.
Говорящий 6: Просто, чтобы это было применимо человечески. Не знаю уж там как.
Говорящий 7: Да, ну это вот, типа, слэш стик, и он тебе ответ выдает стикерами,
Говорящий 4: вот как в этом, на
Говорящий 3: доске можно, на холсте.
Говорящий 3: да
Говорящий 7: ребята
Говорящий 6: давайте
Говорящий 1: еще еще какие вопросы
Говорящий 7: у нас остались по
Говорящий 1: партнерке у меня еще одна прям тема прям на три минуты
Говорящий 6: от вас на
Говорящий 7: про эту тему или про другую какую -то про другую ну тогда надо заканчивать мне кажется уже все хватит чтобы следующий раз сделать игорь
Говорящий 7: давайте закругляться уже прям интенсивно и круто все обсудили кучу информацию прям я Я уже сам буду что -то делать.
Говорящий 1: Супер.